the opening scene begins with a
narration telling us about the outbreak
of the third world war in the early 21st
century that significantly affected
human civilization after the war the
survivors sought to create a conflict
free world and of concern that Humanity
cannot possibly survive a fourth global
conflict we then cut to libbera a
totalitarian citystate established by
the survivors they blame human emotion
as the root cause for War as a result
any activity or object that stimulates
emotion is strictly banned in the city
those in violation are labeled as sense
offenders and are sentenced to death and
men in their 40s with mustaches are
still Prime suspects the population is
forced to take a daily injection of a
drug prium 2 in order to suppress
emotion making them cold-hearted beings
libria is governed by the tetr Graton
Council headed by father who
communicates propaganda via large video
screens at the Pinnacle of law
enforcement are the Graton cleric
soldiers who are highly trained in the
martial arts of gunata these cler lyics
frequently raid homes to search for and
Destroy emotion-provoking materials such
as art literature and music and
ultimately execute violators on site
outside the city there's an abandoned
area called the nether where a
resistance group called The Underground
carries out illegal activities one day a
Graton cleric John Preston and his
partner Errol Partridge lead their
special force to raid those Rebels soon
after a fierce gunfight ensues between
the two parties forcing the underground
group to retreat when the cleric Force
comes across an unknown number of of
resistance members barricading
themselves inside a room they called Jon
to deal with them with firearms in both
hands Jon breaks into the room and waits
in the dark until the rebels stop firing
upon calculating the number and location
of the insurgents he starts shooting in
all directions with great accuracy and
efficiency while being out of the line
of fire following this the clerics
search for ec10 rated materials objects
known to have emotional content they
soon find a huge collection of books and
paintings including the Mona Lisa you
can leave that one it's overrated says
JN after verifying its authenticity
though Jon orders the men to set it
Ablaze on their way back to the
headquarters JN notices that his partner
has taken a poetry book instead of
turning it in for incineration when
questioned arrol tells him that he
wanted to personally log it himself
because the team doesn't always keep
proper records of forbidden materials
later on JN goes to see Vice Council
Dupont to report about the recent raid
during this Dupont wonders how Jon
manages to sense when someone feels
strong emotions but the latter has no
answer for this when Dupont asks about
his family Jon coldly replies that his
wife was executed for being a sense
offender leaving him a single father of
two After exiting the vice council's
office he proceeds to the evidentiary
Department to review records only to
discover that arrol hasn't submitted any
evidence for weeks suspicious he goes to
the nether and finds arrol reading the
Forbidden book when he confronts him
arrol laments that people have lost
everything that makes them human JN
reminds him that there's no war or
murder in this new world but the latter
contends that he'd gladly pay the price
to make humans feel emotions again he
then tries to reach for his gun but Jon
is able to sense it and guns him down
without hesitation a suitable fate for
anyone who enjoys poetry back at home
John's son Robbie informs him that he
witnessed a boy crying earlier he asks
if he should report it to the
authorities to which Jon affirms after
retiring to bed JN dreams of his wife
being arrested when the authorities
broke in he quickly disarmed two men but
he stopped as soon as they revealed his
wife was a sense offender before being
taken away she kissed him and asked him
not to forget get her but he probably
didn't care because he can't feel shed
the next morning while getting ready Jon
accidentally drops his morning vial of
prium Robbie notices this so he reminds
his father to stop by the equilibrium
Center to get a replacement however when
Jon arrives at the center he discovers
that it's temporarily closed due to
trouble caused by some terrorists just
then errol's replacement Andrew Brandt
comes to pick Jon up for their next raid
at a suspected sense offender named
Mary's house upon arrival Jon pushes
Mary against the mirror but he freezes
when he's reminded of of his wife this
woman is also a woman he somehow manages
to recover and proceeds to look around
the house they soon discover a secret
room filled with ec10 rated stuff
knowing that she would be executed Mary
grabs an officer's gun and aims it at
Jon Andrew tries to shoot her in
retaliation but Jon stops him arguing
that they still need her to locate her
Associates Andrew feels that something
is a Miss but he decides to comply with
his senior's order later during
interrogation Jon asks her about the
other Rebels but she ignores the
questions and instead asks him about his
purpose for living he replies that his
purpose is to serve libria and Safeguard
the continuity of society unsatisfied
Mary despises him for living an
emotionless life and Compares his life
with a moving clock which is just
passing time the following morning Jon
wakes up After experiencing a bad dream
he then quickly peels off the tint on
the window of his room allowing him to
see the sunrise for the first time the
captivating sight leaves him in awe and
sensing unfamiliar emotions he hurries
to the bathroom to load a dose of prium
into the syringe gun however after some
contemplation he opts not to take it and
hides it behind the mirror upon arriving
at the headquarters Jon is informed
about their next mission of eliminating
another group of sense offenders during
the raid a man rushes towards him so
Andrew guns him down when Jon catches
the guy he accidentally stares into his
eyes and sees the life leaving his body
upset by the things he's noticing now he
immediately drops the body only to feel
worse when he notices blood on his hands
while the officers kill all the rebels
Jon discovers a secret room filled with
ec10 items he looks around for a while
and plays music this overwhelms him with
emotions breaking him down into tears
amazing what a little Lincoln Park can
do afterwards JN watches as the team
burns down all the illicit stuff in a
secret room just then an officer informs
them that they found some dogs kept by
members of the underground Andrew orders
the team to eliminate all of them Jon
tries to object but he can't think of
any good reason forcing him to comply
amidst this one of the puppies tries to
escape and Jon grabs it before it gets
away Andrew tells him to toss it back
down but the overwhelmed Jon takes it
away claiming that it should be tested
for disease his hesitation causes Andrew
to grow suspicious towards him disturbed
by The Continuous killing of innocent
people Jon visits Dupont and suggests
that sense offenders be interrogated
instead of being Flatout eliminated
however Dupont says that they have to
follow father's orders which is to
eliminate insurgents on site that
evening Jon tries to smuggle the puppy
out of the headquarters by hiding it in
his car trunk upon driving to the nether
he releases the puppy urging it to go
away but it persistently follows him
unable to abandon the creature Jon
places it back in the trunk and also
gives his coat for warmth right then
some patrolling officers surround him
demanding identification turns out that
his ID card is in the coat inside the
trunk which he can't open he doesn't
want to be come John Wick the officers
then snatch his car keys and proceed to
inspect it just before they open the
trunk one of the officers recognizes him
and apologizes for the trouble
unfortunately the puppy then barks
alerting the officers they open the
trunk and discover the puppy prompting
them to hold Jon at gunpoint now that
he's caught Jon fights the officers and
swiftly executes everyone with their own
guns the next day he is seen in the
headquarters practicing his fighting
moves not long after he's joined by
Andrew and the two engage in a friendly
fight during this Andrew claims that he
knows Jon is unable to move on from the
earlier raid incident but the latter
brushes this off after practice Andrew
tells him to get ready as they're going
for another raid in the nether later
during the operation Jon comes across a
group of rebels but refrains from EX
them instead he guides them away from
the authorities even clashing with some
officers along the way however he
accidentally leads them into a room
where Andrew and other exterminators are
waiting as a result the rebels are lined
up against the wall for execution Jon
attempts to persuade the officers to
take them for interrogation instead but
Andrew reminds him of Father's orders
with no other choice Jon walks away
leaving the rebels to be executed
afterwards Jon visits the morg and
expresses remorse to errol's body for
killing him he goes through his
belongings and stumbles upon a
photograph with Freedom written on the
back he then visits Mary and asks her
about arrol when she refuses to
recognize him Jon shows her a photo of
her and arrol together furthermore he
reveals that he's the one who killed him
this Revelation fills her with rage so
she immediately grabs a pen in an
attempt to stab him John blocks her
attack and pins her down finally
realizing that they were lovers as he
stares at her he's reminded of his wife
prompting him to walk away in the
aftermath Jon continues gathering
information about errol's involvement
with the resistance group he remembers a
place called Freedom reading room where
a teacher reads the manifesto to young
men he confronts the teacher and
threatens him into divulging details
about arol the teacher then reveals that
arrol often came here to meet with a man
named Jurgen additionally Jon discovers
a secret compartment on the opposite
side of the room's wall upon breaking in
he meets Jurgen who admits that they've
been observing him for a long time the
man then leads Jon to the underground
where Rebels have made a small community
before further discussion Jon is put on
a polygraph test to make sure that he's
feeling emotions upon confirming his
loyalty towards them Jurgen finally
reveals their plan to assassinate father
and dismantle prium production bringing
the council down since it'll be
difficult for the rebels to do so Jurgen
asks Jon to help them to which the
latter agrees later that day Jon is
summoned by Dupont who reveals that
there's a traitor in the upper ranks of
the clerics although the vice Council
has some doubt towards Jon he assigns
him the task of unmasking the traitor
Jon then returns home and hides another
dose of proteum behind the mirror the
following day JN goes to the
headquarters and watches the preparation
for Mary execution on video monitors
this prompts Recollections of his wife
leading him to watch the footage of her
execution he is distraught to see
himself standing completely emotionless
during that time wanting to make up for
his mistake he runs towards the
incineration room to save Mary sadly
it's too late as she is already put
inside the chamber and the turbines have
been started Jon tries his best to hold
back his tears as he sees her die upon
walking out he's unable to Bear her
death causing him to have an emotional
breakdown at the same time Andrew spots
him and arrests him for being a traitor
and a little taken to DuPont
Andrew discloses Jon's involvement with
the rebels also accusing him of killing
their fellow officers but unexpectedly
Jon turns the tables and accuses Andrew
of being the traitor he claims that
Andrew was the one who killed their
officers during the previous raid
hearing this Dupont checks the gun used
in the officer's deaths and discovers
that it belongs to Andrew here it's
revealed that Jon had cleverly swapped
guns the other night when a group of
rebels were executed Andrew tries to
argue that he's being framed but Dupont
has his officers arrest him following
this Dupont notifies Jon that his house
will be searched as a formality to which
the latter shows no objection but as
soon as he exits the vice council's
office he rushes home to destroy the
hidden vials he quickly removes the
mirror only to discover that the vials
are already gone just then Robbie enters
the bathroom and admits that he removed
it to protect his father the boy further
reveals that he and his sister had
stopped taking prium themselves ever
since their mother died in the next
scene Jon collaborates with the rebels
to start their revolutionary plan first
of all he contacts the council and
informs them that he has located the
rebels leaders following this the
authorities arrest all the leaders of
the Rebel groups this makes it easier
for Jon to convince Dupont to Grant him
an audience with father he is then
dressed up in white attire for the
meeting before that he is subjected to a
polygraph test just for safety purposes
in the midst of this Andrew shows up
revealing that he was never arrested
just then father appears on the screen
and discloses that it was part of a ruse
to expose Jon and to infiltrate the
rebels in addition father unveils his
true identity as none other than Dupont
disclosing that the real father had
perished many years ago this deception
fills John with rage and as a result he
pulls out his pistols from his sleeves
before starting to gun down every man in
the room Jon goes on a killing spree
taking down all the guards and making
his way towards DuPont's office upon
reaching it he finds Andrew standing
beside Dupont as his bodyguard as he
steps inside the room he is surrounded
by a group of skilled Swordsmen Jon in a
swift action retrieves a sword and kills
all of those men in a matter of seconds
after this Andrew comes forward for a
duel but he proves no match for JN as
the ladder finishes him off with three
quick slices seeing this Dupont reaches
for his gun in an attempt to shoot him
down however Jon is so fast that he
grabs a gun from the ground before
engaging in a gun caught to Showdown
being a professional in this Jon easily
overpowers Dupont and ultimately shoots
him to death who needs a full Uprising
when you've got Christian Bale in the
aftermath Jon demolishes the entire
command center that is broadcast ing
father's propaganda across libria the
movie ends as the rebels start exploding
the prium manufacturing plants signaling
the Inception of the Revolution
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching